>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: THE MEXICAN DRUG WAR
HAS BECOME A LOT BLOODIER THAN
MOST AMERICANS UNDERSTAND.
IT'S NEVER COVERED HERE.
HERE ARE THE FACTS.
MORE 23,000 PEOPLE WERE MURDERED
IN MEXICO JUST LAST YEAR AS DRUG
CARTELS FIGHT EACH OTHER AND THE
MEXICAN GOVERNMENT.
DRUGS CONTINUE TO POUR ACROSS
THE AMERICAN BORDER IN MASSIVE
AMOUNTS KILLING TENS OF
THOUSANDS EVER AMERICANS.
FEAR OF LETTING THIS INTO OUR
COUNTRY IS ONE REASON THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION CALLED FOR A
BORDER WALL.
NOT EVERYBODY IS ON BOARD.
WE DISCUSSED THIS ISSUE WITH
JORGE RAMOS.
HERE IT IS.
WHEN LAST WE SPOKE YOU SAID THE
U.S. HAS 11 MILLION ILLEGAL
IT'S AMERICA'S FAULT THESE
PEOPLE WERE HERE.
THEY WERE LURED BY JOBS.
MEXICO NEEDS AMERICAN MONEY SENT
BACK BY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS HERE.
WHY SHOULDN'T WE BLAME THE
GOVERNMENT OF MEXICO FOR THAT?
>> WELL, FIRST EVER ALL I DON'T
CALL THEM ILLEGAL ALIENS.
NO HUMAN BEING IS ILLEGAL.
>> YOU CAN USE IT IF YOU WANT.
>> Tucker: IT'S THE LEGAL TERM
IN U.S. GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS.
>> I WILL GO THE MORAL POINT OF
VIEW.
YOU SHOULD NOT CALL ANYONE
ILLEGAL.
>> Tucker: EXCEPT THOSE WHO ARE
I WON'T BE BILLEDBILLED -- BULLI
I WON'T BE BILLEDBILLED -- BULLD
I WON'T BE BILLEDBILLED -- BULLA
CALL THEM WHAT THEY ARE.
THE GOVERNMENT OF MEXICO COULD
NOT DO WITHOUT THEM.
>> THEY GET BILLION DOLLARS FROM
MEXICOS IN THE UNITED STATES.
BUT UNDOCUMENTED ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS ARE HERE BECAUSE WE
NEED THEM.
YOU MIGHT NOT WANT TO ADMIT.
THEY ARE SUPPLY AND DEMAND.
THEM.
>> Tucker: I KNOW YOU ARE BIG ON
LECTURING AMERICANS ON THEIR
GOVERNMENT.
THEY DON'T SERVE ITS OWN PEOPLE
IMMIGRANTS AS A PRESSURE RELIEF
VALVE.
>> I THINK YOU CHOSE THE WRONG
GUEST TO DEFEND THE MEXICAN
GOVERNMENT.
I HAVE CRITICIZED THEM FOR
DECADES.
IT'S REALLY CORRUPT.
MORE THAN 20,000 PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN KILLED BECAUSE OF VIOLENCE
IN MEXICO.
WE WILL HAVE ELECTIONS IN MEXO
TO JULY 1st AND I HOPE THAT
CHANGES.
I AM NO ONE TO DEFEND THE
MEXICAN GOVERNMENT.
THERE IS A LACK OF DEMOCRACY AND
TRANSPARENCY.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE SAYING OUR
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ARE AT FAULT.
THE SINGLE LARGEST SOURCE OF
HEROIN IN MEXICO.
WHY SHOULDN'T WE BE ANGRY AT THE
GOVERNMENT OF MEXICO FOR
ALLOWING THIS TO HAPPEN HERE?
>> WELL, BECAUSE THERE IS A
DIFFERENT WAYING SEEING THAT.
YOU SEE IT AS MEXICO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE DRUGS COMING
TO THIS COUNTRY.
THE WAY PEOPLE IN MEXICO AND
COLUMBIA AND OTHER
LATIN-AMERICAN COUNTRIES, THEY
SEE IT AS AS LONG AS YOU HAVE 25
MILLION AMERICANS WHO USE
ILLEGAL DRUGS IT'S THE PROBLEM
OF SUPPLY AND DEMAND.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT YOU DO AT
THE BORDER AND HAVE A HUGE WALL.
DRUGS WILL KEEP COMING.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> Tucker: IF YOU FLOOD A
COMMUNICATE WITH ILLEGAL DRUGS,
DOES DRUG USE GO UP?
THE ANSWER IS YES.
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
TUCKER, IF YOU HAVE 25 MILLION
AMERICANS WHO USE AN ILLEGAL
DRUG IN THE LAST MONTH, WHAT ARE
>> Tucker: IF A DROPPED A TON OF
HEROIN INTO YOUR ZIP CODE, DO
YOU THINK YOU WOULD SEE A HIGHER
RATE OF HEROIN ADDICTION?
IT WOULD BE MY FAULT.
>> Tucker: OH, 15 YEARS OLD ARE
DESPERATE FOR CHEAP HEROIN.
LET'S BE HONEST.
NOT BUILDING A WALL IS NOT
IT.
>> THE WALL WOULD BE USELESS.
HISTORY.
HOW MANY ARE USELESS?
>> I WILL GIVE YOU JUST A FEW
ARGUMENTS.
45% OF ALL UNDOCUMENTED ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS COME BY PLANE OR WITH
A VISA.
>> Tucker: WHAT PERCENT?
>> 45 PERCENT.
YOU CAN CHECK IT.
>> Tucker: I THINK THAT NUMBER
IS RIGHT.
BUT THERE ARE STILL HALF A
MILLION PEOPLE APPREHENDED AT
THE BORDER EVERY YEAR ON FOOT.
THAT DOESN'T ACCOUNT FOR PEOPLE
WHO MADE IT ACROSS.
YOU HAVE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE COMING ACROSS WITH NO
WALL.
YOU HAVE TONS AND TONS OF DRUGS.
WHY IS IT IMMORAL TO TRY TO STOP
BEING INVADED BY MEXICO.
THAT MORE MEXICANS ARE LIVING IN
THE U.S.
>> Tucker: I AM SAYING TONS OF
DRUGS AND HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE.
TONS OF HEROIN AND HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ARE COMING
ACROSS.
MANY WOULD BE STOPPED BY THE
ON OUR FRONT DOOR?
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
WHY SHOULD WE BE SCOLDED FOR
PROTECTING OUR OWN COUNTRY?
>> I AGREE WITH YOU.
EVERY SINGLE COUNTRY HAS THE
AGAINST THE WALL.
>> THE WALL THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
WANTS TO BUILD WOULD BE USELESS.
THERE IS NO INVASION FROM
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ARE COMING
TO THIS COUNTRY.
THE UNDEFEATED POPULATION HAS
REMAINED STABLE IN THIS COUNTRY
THE UNDOCUMENTED POPULATION IS?
>> WE.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE HERE
HERE ILLEGALLY.
>> 11 MILLION.
>> Tucker: SAY 11 MILLION.
THOSE PEOPLE ARE LIVING PROOF
THAT WE DON'T HAVE CONTROL OF
OUR BORDER.
I HOPE YOU CAN SUM IT UP IN ONE
WALL TO STOP SOME PERCENTAGE OF
THOSE PEOPLE AND SOME PERCENTAGE
OF THE HEROIN WHEN EVERY OTHER
WALL IN EVERY OTHER COUNTRY ON
PLANET EARTH HA HAS AN EFFECT IN
STOPPING PEOPLE AND DRUGS FROM
GETTING INTO THE COUNTRY IT
SEPARATES?
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
>> BECAUSE IT'S A MYTH TO
BELIEVE THAT THE BORDER RIGHT
NOW IS MORE INSECURE.
IT'S A MYTH.
AS LONG AS YOU HAVE CONSUMERS
WHO USE DRUGS IN THIS COUNTRY,
DRUGS WILL COME THROUGH THE PORT
OF ENTRY OR TUNNELS.